sensibiliser à la transition écologique
c'est l'objectif que se donne la
communauté d'agglomération de
Rambouillet territoire le samedi 23
septembre se tiendra la journée du
développement durable à la Bergerie
nationale et pour en parler avec nous
Thomas gourland bonjour bonjour vous
êtes le président de Rambouillet
territoire pourquoi est-ce que c'est
important d'organiser ce type de journée
parce que il faut sensibiliser les
enjeux environnementaux les enjeux de
qualité de vie de préservation de
l'environnement sont maintenant majeurs
plus personne n'en doute et le rôle de
l'agglomération de Rambouillet
territoire c'est justement de faire en
sorte d'encore plus expliquer les enjeux
sensibiliser les personnes et surtout
faire bouger les gestes quotidien pour
enfin pouvoir agir et alors quel type
d'animation qu'on va pouvoir retrouver à
ces journées le maître robot de ces
journées c'est l'interactivité et le
côté ludique il faut à la fois qu'on
puisse pratiquer qu'on puisse
expérimenter puis aussi apprendre de
manière ludique sans s'ennuyer c'est ça
les deux grandes thématiques et nous
aurons quatre grands quatre grands
ateliers qui seront fait sur ces trois
journées et alors l'environnement c'est
un des enjeux dont on parle le plus
aujourd'hui dans notre société est-ce
que c'est un événement qui rassemble
chaque année effectivement on a eu un
grand succès l'année dernière on a fait
la première édition des Journées du
développement durable compte tenu de la
fréquentation que nous avons eu on a
considéré j'ai considéré qu'il fallait
évidemment le reconduire et donc on a
maintenant changé de lieu et on est ici
à la Bergerie Nationale dont je remercie
encore la directrice et l'ensemble de
ces de ces agents pour leur accueil et
cet événement à quel type de public et
ce qui s'adresse exactement parce qu'on
sait que les jeunes se saisissent assez
facilement de ce type de sujet est-ce
que ça attire aussi les adultes ou les
seniors effectivement les jeunes sont un
excellent vecteur pour transmettre les
messages environnementaux et les bonnes
pratiques donc nous aurons deux
premières journées le jeudi et le
vendredi ou les accueillons les éclats
de CM1 et CM2 du territoire qui
viendront sur deux journées pratiquées
l'ensemble des ateliers et on espère que
finalement qui vient feront venir leur
propre parents sur la journée du samedi
on sait que les enfants sont des
influenceurs mais et vous l'avez dit
tout à l'heure donc quatre grands thèmes
rythmeront cette journée donc le cycle
de l'eau la biodiversité la gestion des
déchets et la biodiversité et la
mobilité pardon alors dans la partie
biodiversité cette année il y aura des
apiculteurs est-ce que c'est important
de les convier de les mettre en avant
alors c'est très important et ça fait
plusieurs années que nous travaillons
avec le canif le conservatoire de la
baignoire d'Île-de-France puisque nous
avons 36 rue chez qui sont disposés sur
l'ensemble du territoire cruchet
représentant une commune de Rambouillet
territoire le canif
œuvre tous les jours toute l'année pour
la conservation de cette abbé noir on
sait bien que l'abeille est absolument
essentielle en terme de préservation de
l'environnement puisqu'elle participe à
la pollinisation et donc il faut
absolument agir en ce sens et c'est pour
ça qu'ils sont là ils sont évidemment
les bienvenus et il y aura aussi
beaucoup de jeux est-ce que c'est un
moyen aussi
d'aborder l'environnement de manière
plus ludique parce que c'est vrai que
quand on en parle c'est assez critique
il y a deux leviers dans le côté ludique
des choses la première chose c'est qu'on
sait bien que tous autant qu'on est
lorsqu'on approche les choses de manière
sous l'angle du jeu on apprend plus
facilement et plus aisément mais aussi
derrière cela c'est aussi de montrer que
les enjeux écologiques c'est pas
forcément que de l'anxiété c'est aussi
des perspectives c'est aussi des
possibilités de changer les choses et
c'est ces deux volets là que l'aspect
ludique apporte alors on est obligé d'en
parler par rapport à l'actualité d'hier
on a l'Organisation météorologique
mondiale qui indique que les objectifs
qui étaient fixés pour 2030 en termes de
développement durable ne seront pas
atteints malheureusement est-ce que vous
sentez que les citoyens aujourd'hui
peuvent aussi désespérer et se dire que
les gestes du quotidien comme vous
l'aviez dit tout à l'heure sont
peut-être un peu trop minimes le maître
mot enfin l'approche que je porte en
termes de gestion des sujets de
l'environnementaux c'est une approche
positive et une approche
comment dirais-je de progrès et de
résolution des problèmes il faut pas
avoir une anxiété par rapport à ça et se
recroqueviller au contraire il faut se
saisir des sujets et les approcher de
manière rationnelle scientifique et
positive encore une fois pour pouvoir
les résoudre donc c'est tout l'enjeu de
ces journées de développement durable
c'est montrer que nous pouvons agir
chacun de nous au quotidien dans nos
gestes quotidiens dans dans
l'environnement dans lequel nous sommes
et c'est
itérativement lorsque chacun aura mis la
main à la pâte comme tout le monde
maintenant est engagé dans cette
technique là je suis certain que nous
allons réussir et d'ailleurs vous êtes
aussi vous très actif sur la question
vous aviez saisi ces sujets notamment
via l'Agenda 21 ou le plan climat air
énergie territoriale est-ce que ces
journées c'est aussi l'occasion de
montrer que le territoire est actif
quant à ces sujets que voilà vous vous
êtes très actif sur cette question
exactement en fait vous avez merci de le
mentionner l'Agenda 21 et le plan climat
air énergie territoriale ont été votées
et mis en action par embrouiller
territoire l'ensemble des services de
Rambouillet territoire sont mobilisés
sur ces trois journées le service du
cycle de l'eau le service de la gestion
des milieux nos partenaires que sont le
SICTOM et si très bas pour le traitement
des ordures ménagères notre service de
mobilité ce que je veux dire par là
c'est que cet agenda 21 et ce plan
climat air énergétique territorial il se
traduit concrètement depuis déjà de
nombreux mois et l'objet de cette de ces
journées c'est de montrer ce que nous
avons déjà fait et ce qui reste encore à
faire alors pour cette journée du 23
septembre vous vous attendez combien de
personnes le maximum j'espère que tu en
sera avec nous comme il l'est
aujourd'hui compte tenu du succès que
nous avons eu l'année dernière et de la
sensibilité que l'ensemble des personnes
ont eu partant des habitants du
territoire haut je suis certain que nous
serons débordés et bien alors si vous
aussi vous souhaitez participer à cet
événement sachez qu'il est gratuit et
c'est samedi 23 septembre de 11h à 18h
voilà c'est la fin de cette émission
merci beaucoup Thomas gourland d'avoir
accepté de nous accorder cet entretien
en attendant le 23 septembre je vous
souhaite de passer une excellente soirée
sur TV 78